Luciana no es francesa desde 1803 sin
embargo en este barrio de Nuevo Orleans
el presidente mahon parece estar en casa
a esta ciudad cuna del jazz el jefe de
estado francés vino hablar de cultura
para cerrar un viaje oficial donde se
trataron muchos temas
es también una oportunidad para sellar
alianzas en energía clima y economía y
una forma de desarrollar nuestra
diplomacia cultural y lingüística en una
tierra que defiende el francés y lo
sigue defendiendo
tras pasear Por el barrio francés
Emmanuel Macao finalizó la jornada con
un discurso en el Museo anunció la
creación de un fondo para el aprendizaje
del francés en todo el mundo y la
contratación de profesores para
enseñarlo en el continente americano
Este programa es parte de todo lo que
queremos seguir fortaleciendo para
nuestra francofonía porque soy
convencido de que el francés Es un
idioma del futuro por la demografía de
muchos países francófonos Especialmente
del continente africano vamos a tener un
crecimiento demográfico extraordinario
en los próximos años
unos minutos antes de subir al escenario
Emanuel mapón anunció que había conocido
a elon musk una discusión con el jefe de
tesla y Twitter donde supuestamente
planteó el tema de la moderación en la
red social y el desarrollo de autos
eléctricos en suelo francés